Film Courage: What are three mistakes screenwriters
make with loglines?
Naomi Beaty, Writer, Screenwriting teacher
and Consultant: The three that I tend to see
are stopping at the setup.
So describing just the initial situation and
not really giving us any indication of what
is the meat of the movie if that makes sense?
Often when we come at stories, we come with
an interesting what if and that is a great
entry point into a story but then you sort
of have to develop that continuation of the
conflict, right?
What is the real problem that they are trying
to solve?
In a logline if you just give me the setup
I don’t know if you’ve thought that through.
If you’ve come up with the story part of
your screenplay I know that you’ve come
up with a situation but not necessarily a
story so that is the first mistake that I
see people make with loglines.
The second one is not having an act two which
is a little bit different from the first one.
If you’re conveying to me what’s happening
in your movie but it’s something sort of
transitory or that it can be done in one scene
or one minute then that raises a little bit
of a red flag because then it feels like maybe
you don’t have enough to sustain an entire
movie.
The third mistake I see a lot is packing too
much detail into your longline.
Usually this happens after somebody has written
the script and so they know so much about
the story and they’ve fallen in love with
everything that they’ve written then they
try to distill all of that down into one sentence
and it’s really hard because they have all
these details that they know and all of these
subplots and supporting characters and character
arcs and all this stuff.
So they will try to jam all of this into one
sentence and that just makes it confusing
and we want that logline to ultimately just
really convey a solid sense of what that movie
we will be watching if we sit down in the
theater.
So we need to know what is that main conflict
(that big conflict) that we’re going to
be tracking over the course of that movie
and have a sense of the nature of the action
that we’re watching on screen.
What are sort of the broad strokes things
that that character is doing in pursuit of
that story goal.
That’s really what you’re trying to get
into the logline and like I will say you can
start with those sort of 4 foundational elements,
your protagonist, the story goal, the antagonist
or main force of opposition and the stakes.
Start there and write one sentence with those
elements and that should give you a really
good start for your logline.
You may need to add a few details but that
way you’re starting with a solid foundation
and then you can add details as necessary
rather than starting by putting everything
you know about the story into a story and
then trying to pull things out.
Film Courage: Going back to the logline example
that we did (and I don’t know if this video
will come out before the other one referring
to this).
People might be confused to what I’m referring
to but the logline that I gave you was definitely
confusing, there was too much (information)
in it.
So we cleaned it up and we found out that
it wasn’t just about the writing group,
it was more about her finding love.
So that was getting to the meat of it?
Naomi: Yes, because I think if you were going
to write that script it sounded like the story
that you wanted to tell was really about this
mismatched romance and so that’s what we
want to convey in the logline because then
when I read the script or I watch the movie
that’s the movie that I’m getting.
You’re not telling me that DANGEROUS MINDS
story.
You’re telling me THE ENGLISH PATIENT or
whatever and those are both movies that work
but I want to know which one I’m getting
before I pick up that script or before I go
see that movie so making sure that you convey
a true sense of the story you want to tell
in that logline, that’s what we’re looking
for.
Film Courage: What situation will a screenwriter
use loglines?
When will this come up?
Naomi: I think there are a few different situations.
In the classes that I teach we usually we
usually start with logline as the first iteration
of your story.
So just like you and I were talking about
what’s that story that you actually want
to write, we use loglines as a way to figure
that out.
What is this story that you’re trying to
tell.
In that case we put more of the focus on getting
those essentials of the story into the logline
so we can tell if that foundation is solid
before we start developing the story further.
But you might also use a logline in a query
letter or to pitch to somebody in person (that
elevator pitch of the story).
So if you’re using that version of the logline
you’re probably going to think a little
more carefully about the language that you
use because it’s not for internal use anymore
you are actually presenting this as this is
the product essentially that I’m trying
to pitch you.
So you will probably be a little bit more
careful about word choice and a little more
conscious of getting or really conveying the
tone of the story and that feel of the movie
if you can through the word choice and through
the language and the way you’re describing
the situation.
Film Courage: Can you explain foundation?
I realize this is jumping a little bit off
topic.
Naomi: Yes, when I talk about the foundation
that is just me referring to the kind of essential
building blocks of your story.
So the protagonist, the story goal, the antagonist
or the opposition and the stakes.
Those are the things that every story needs.
You kind of have to have those elements and
so that is where I start if I’m helping
someone figure out what story they are telling
or what’s not working about their story,
you just have to start with the foundation
layer and then work your way up right?
So we make sure that that is solid and then
we talk about the other pieces that go into
your story work.
Film Courage: What if someone says “I don’t
have a really strong antagonist but I have
a really great sidekick character.”
Is this because there is no opposition?
There is nothing that this hero needs to overcome?
Naomi: Yes, that could be.
That would be my first instinct.
If someone says they are writing that doesn’t
have an antagonist it wouldn’t necessarily
be a deal breaker but I would want to know
where is that conflict coming from right?
Because if you are telling a story where sort
of nothing goes wrong it’s probably either
going to be a pretty short story or we are
just going to get bored pretty quick.
So I would question where is that conflict
coming from?
If it’s not sort of a traditional direct
conflict that we can see between two people
or a person or a group or that type of thing,
then what is making this journey for your
protagonist so difficult or so interesting?